says good evening good evening Sakura
this is for
you that's your favorite color
right and I brought
s
she says
good your cooking is very good
Sakura I know
is I meant that for
you for
you
time
note
speee
spe what's
going
who was
that uhas
says I do not
know oh
how is the
food
it's you got
that the very first time I saw your face
you had the most wonderful glow about
you it made me so happy and when I heard
your voice for the first time I swear it
was the most adorable sound in the
world
do you have any more to say Mr
White and you're
pretty Mr
White Mr White
I I just can't deal with him translating
every single word that I
say oh my
God
good
good good very
how is the
food
it's can I have a strawberry sure
okay oh my
God oh my
God
cut did it work did it work